[Music]
you know what a lot of celebrities went
out last night i'm reading about it
today yes it's true last night lady gaga
dressed up as a marijuana plant
that's true yeah 20 minutes later she
realized it was halloween ran home and
put on a costume so
she was a stapler i think
you know conservative following what's
going on in politics right now besides
the presidential election a little bit
conservatives are furious with chris
christie yeah because he's been saying
nice things about president obama
chris christie's saying nice things
about president obama that's how they've
been working together and acting like
grown-ups yeah yeah
and the conservatives are mad about it
well today rush limbaugh joked about
president obama and chris christie being
gay lovers
yeah obama and christie are furious said
they give a formal response as soon as
they get back from the caribbean
great times
one drink
[Music]
lance armstrong's troubles continue the
international olympic committee is
investigating lance armstrong for the
bronze medal he won at the 2000 olympics
yeah little tip for the ioc if lance was
on steroids and he came in third you
might want to take a peek at the guys
with gold and silver
doesn't that make sense yeah i am
i'm just trying to help them right
uh there are rumors that north korean
leader kim jong-un's wife
is pregnant
isn't that nice yeah
yeah the sonic sonogram shows a healthy
boy who looks like a 40 year old lesbian
[Applause]
[Music]
it's wearing are you saying it has
glasses in utero yes oh okay in utero
wow in utero
that works with a kennedy accent in
utero
how do you guys feel star wars franchise
has been sold to disney
[Applause]
it's it's the booze versus the woos
yay
yeah well after selling star wars to
disney george lucas says he's going to
donate the majority of the proceeds to
charity
good for him
[Music]
yeah lucas said he'll donate to star
wars fans favorite cause grown-ups
without partners
[Music]
i pissed off a lot of people here right
now
you'll get yours
[Music]
i'll get on my x-wing and destroy you
brad pitt brad pitt has donated one
apparently that's all i need for you
someone i'm just gonna come out here and
just mention random hot guys yeah
welcome to the show brad pitt
good night everyone we're done
[Music]
brad pitt has donated 100 000
to back gay marriage
yeah today a gay spokesman said it's
nice to think that brad pitt is behind
us
thank you
thank you very much
anyone watch the x factor last night
well okay then
i didn't either
uh
i was busy working out
you don't just get this body uh
last night on the x factor khloe
kardashian had a nip slip
yeah after hearing about it people in
the north he said you know maybe losing
power isn't so bad
yeah
this was
[Music]
that joke's okay i don't care but it got
kind of a
yeah
we can do it
fascinating scientists have discovered
an elephant at a south korean zoo that
can imitate human speech
true
so far all the elephant has said is
enough with the friggin peanuts
i'll tell you something
my parents are going to love that one
you guys are cool but my parents don't
you think that's why yeah but they won't
like friggin
they'll be like couldn't you say
something other than they won't know
what friggin is all right all right they
think it's a yachting term